well I looked at the first one only
figures to look at the sequel during
this sequel month its Mickey's twice
upon a Christmas and you know when
people ask what's the difference between
something that's good for kids yet not
necessarily for adults or bad for kids
and not necessarily for adults either
this is a perfect example the first once
upon a Christmas was a simple but humble
and sweet story it was expressive it was
kind it was a little corny but the
effort really shows and pays off this is
a cash-in you can smell from a mile away
just look at it I mean look at it
I know it's direct-to-dvd so the CGI
isn't gonna be like Pixar quality but
look at it the first one was
direct-to-dvd - and you can see all the
great drawings all the great atmosphere
expressions it was impressive by its own
standards this even by its own standards
it's cheap looking and lame and not
written well and heartless and empty and
just like I said I'm obvious Kashyap
okay well I guess I should go over all
the stories but that almost seems
pointless because we're in the first
film there's only three stories that
seem reasonable enough this one it's
like eight yeah they just throw a bunch
of oh man - whether they make sense or
not it becomes so much overload that the
motivations aren't even established when
the story start the very first story is
just Daisy and Minnie skating well okay
that's fine but for whatever reason
Daisy tries to sabotage Minnie was that
in her character is that something she's
known for
I can see Donald doing that but nothing
about her has ever been established as
this egotistical jealous character and
that many gets really angry - and she
starts fighting back and it's just this
entirely pointless number here's another
kind of mean-spirited story where Donald
comes home from work he's really tired
he just wants to relax but then Daisy
and the boys all want to go Christmas
shopping and they force him to come with
he gets angry because Christmas is being
shoved in his face a just needs a break
from it but he shouldn't be he's wrong
much like Christmas with the Kranks you
should just accept everything about
Christmas and love it all
unconditionally seems like a very
confused
message on one hand I can kinda see what
they're going for like you're just gonna
need that extra effort to make Christmas
special for your kids and your loved
ones and stuff but first of all there is
nephews not as kids I still don't know
where the damn parents are second you
sympathize too much for him I wanted to
be by the fireplace I wanted to have his
hot chocolate I don't want to go out to
the store and have all this
commercialism shoved in his face
somewhere there's a sweet nice idea
trying to get out bites just lost
there's also this lame number about max
bringing his girlfriend to meet his dad
and most of its a pop song that he's not
really singing yeah he never sees lips
move and the song doesn't really match
the atmosphere they're trying to make it
sound like one of those songs you can
hear on the radio but it's not even
vague enough to be a song that you can
hear on the radio they're obviously
saying the dad's gonna embarrass me I
hope he doesn't embarrass me around
Christmas they can't even get whoring
the fake pop song right nobody would
listen to this on their own but the
characters clearly not singing the song
either so it's just entirely confused
remember how Santa Claus was a big deal
in the first one like goofy and Max were
trying to believe but they didn't know
if they did but they wanted to believe
that was a whole big thing in this one
Huey Dewey Louie just mail themselves to
Santa yeah I guess he's not really that
big a deal anymore and look at him talk
about the most generic forgettable Santa
you can imagine sorry Ari are there any
good things about this special I guess
the colors can be kind of nice and
Christmassy every once in a while there
is a good visual joke or a line here
there but for the most part it just
feels shallow I guess it seems silly to
be this hard on a little Christmas
special that's obviously just meant for
little kids but the first one was just a
little Christmas special meant for
little kids and they really did a much
better job they cared they took the time
to write good stories and putting good
animation because it felt like the
respect of the audience was important
they know they can show little kids
anything with Donald and Goofy and
Mickey and stuff but instead they tried
to give something really nice and
meaningful and that's felt by the adults
as well as the children this just feels
like what it most likely is a
last-minute sequel the first one
probably made a lot of money so they had
to squeeze out a sequel and this is
what we got a cheap knockoff with little
to no heart I can't say it's as bad as
some of Disney's other worse anime of
films I mean I can't say it's Chicken
Little or home on the range or move on
to but it just feels lazy and don't get
me wrong I don't know how much time or
money they had to put into this so I
shouldn't judge but it's just how it
feels it feels lazy can you show it to
kids
sure does it get across any
mean-spirited or bad morals little
debatable but none that little kids will
probably get it's just a weak Christmas
cash grab and nothing more if your kids
really dying to see it I guess it's okay
to show but in my opinion die just put
on the first one again
[Music]
you